one of las vegas's best italian
restaurants wants to get some quality
ingredients in your hands and teach you
their ways
i'm joined by the executive chef of la
strega gina marinelli
to tell us more chef gina this sounds
fantastic
what do you guys have going on this
weekend
so this weekend it's going to be our
fourth fish market which we also call
pescaria
so we turn the whole restaurant into
basically a market that resembles
something i would go to in italy
so you can come in and buy all the fresh
seafood that i bring into the restaurant
daily
you can purchase wine you can have a
great lunch it's unlike anything in
vegas it's such a great way to spend
your sunday
that sounds so much fun i love how
you're bringing that authentic italian
experience here to us now
can local stop by and dine while this is
still happening
absolutely we do a different menu that
day we do our piadina which are our
sandwiches
we're going to have some pizzas we're
going to have salads full
bars great way for a sunday so you can
shop and dine or just come pick up some
seafood and go home
it's a really fun day okay so let's say
i go in there and i see some seafood
some fish that looks really great
how do i know how to cook it what do i
do
that's what i'm here for so the great
thing is it's really interactive and i
spend a lot of time with each guest
that's coming in
for our kitchen's open i can even take
you back there show you how to throw a
piece of fish on the grill
show you how to stuff it the right way
answer all your questions
teach you how to cut it for a crudo it's
really something that i'm so
passionate about and i get this day to
really share it with the community
i love that now what sparked your
interest in hosting this event
honestly i always thought of my days off
and where do i go buy seafood
you know and it's yes we're in the
middle of the desert and that's always
something i love grilling seafood at
home
so i thought what a great way for me to
bring in all the beautiful fish i get
from around the world
and give an opportunity for my guests to
come in and buy it and take it home
okay i i gotta know do you have a quick
tip or a trick
in preparing fish something that we
could use in the kitchen
absolutely so biggest thing hot grill
that's always very very important
clean grill so i always take an old rag
dip it in some oil
brush it so it's nice and seasoned and
then i put a bunch of oil on the fit on
the fish skin
throw it down and then i don't touch it
we always get tempted to touch it
let it sit there for a good few minutes
till the marks get there
and then when you go to pull it it will
not get stuck
that's always the thing the skin gets
stuck i've had your creations before and
she knows what she is talking about now
tell us thank you where is la strega
located and again this is happening on
sunday what are the times
so we are located right off of 215 in
town center
it's going to be 11 to 4. i recommend
getting here early because we usually
run out of fish
pretty quickly so get here early start
your sunday and pick up some awesome
seafood from
that sounds like a great time thank you
so much chef gina kendall
i appreciate it bye